turn the map will show five black police
officers are under arrest after fatally
beating a black man everyone involved is
black yet that hasn't stopped the media
from pinning the blame on white
supremacy of course also police
departments across the country have been
lowering their standards in order to
attract new and quote diverse recruits
does that play into the incident in
Memphis plus the Paul Pelosi 911 call is
finally revealed which also reveals the
real story in that whole bizarre
situation a trans figure skater
accidentally gives us the funniest video
of the year so far hands down and the
pop star Sam Smith tries to become the
white male lizzo the results are as
tedious as they are revolting all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the current administration's new year's
tax goals are to spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation that's the the whole
goal really if this is at odds with your
goals if you're tired of government
playing games with your savings and your
retirement plans then you need to get in
touch with the experts at Birch gold
today for over 5 000 years gold has
withstood inflation geopolitical turmoil
and stock market crashes now you can own
gold in a tax shelter retirement account
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals text Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim
your free info kit on gold and then talk
to one of their precious metal
Specialists with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings so text Walsh to 98
9898 and protect yourself with gold
today that's Walsh to 98 98 98 today
on Friday evening after several days of
hype and build up video of the incident
that led to murder charges for five
Memphis police officers was finally
released the body camera uh the body
camera footage is a couple different uh
places where the footage is coming from
in the body camera is harder to
interpret we see Tyree Nichols fighting
with the cops after having been
apparently pulled over for reckless
driving but the footage is sort of
glittery uh blurry and jittery and
difficult to discern
the story is really told by footage from
security cameras mounted to Street lamps
and there we can see the cops take turns
beating and kicking nickels while he's
restrained the five of them together
should have been able to figure out a
way to subdue one man without pummeling
him to death but these officers decided
to use much more Force than what the
situation would seem to require in fact
if you saw the video with the from the
the Street Lamp security uh cameras
without any other contacts you wouldn't
think that it was an arrest at all but
rather like gang Warfare look like
Street violence not officers of the law
executing an arrest
and the end result is that Tyree Nichols
died in the hospital a few days after
the beating
now there's still much we don't know
about this incident and even though the
video is quite brutal it's still always
worth keeping in mind that everyone is
innocent until proven guilty in a court
of law I wouldn't be surprised if more
details emerge in the coming weeks and
months that will that while probably not
exculpatory for the officers it's very
hard to imagine what kind of context
could possibly let them off the hook
here
it might at least help to explain
what exactly was going on
did one or some of these cops have some
sort of personal grudge against Nichols
is there a history here that we haven't
been told about which might explain why
the beating looks so personal I have no
idea hopefully we'll find out more as
time goes on
what I do know though is that this event
whatever precipitated It Whatever
explains it
certainly had absolutely nothing to do
with racism because this was a black man
beaten by black cops who work for a
department run by a black woman in a
majority black City governed by a
majority black City Council
there are no white faces anywhere near
this incident
which means that no honest and
intelligent person could try to pin this
one on whiteness or white supremacy
but unfortunately for all of us honest
and intelligent is a bar too high for
many people especially those in the
media to meet and so leftist activists
and media propagandists immediately went
to work trying to explain how the
actions of five black men under the
leadership of a black woman somehow
represent an act of anti-black racism
van Jones over on CNN got the race
baiting kicked off on Friday night with
an op-ed titled quote the police who
killed Tyree Nichols were black but they
might still have been driven by racism
Jones goes on to explain one of the sad
facts about anti-black racism is that
black people ourselves are not immune to
its pernicious effects society's message
that black people are inferior unworthy
and dangerous is pervasive over many
decades numerous experiments have shown
that these ideas can infiltrate black
Minds as well as white self-hatred is a
real thing at the end of the day it is
the race of the victim who is brutalized
not the race of the violent cop that is
most relevant in determining whether
racial bias is a factor in police
violence whether racial bias is a factor
in police violence it's hard to imagine
five cops of any color beating a white
person to death under similar
circumstances and it's almost impossible
to imagine five black cops giving a
white arrestee the kind of Beatdown that
Nichols allegedly received
there you have it
white people are to blame even for
things that white people don't do van
Jones bases all of this on uh on his own
essentially his own lack of imagination
because he says that uh that it's hard
to imagine a white person treated this
way by cops hard to imagine
and it might indeed be hard for him to
imagine because he works for a media
organization that simply ignores every
occasion where a white person is killed
by police
it's not that Jones can't imagine a
white person falling victim police
brutality it's that he chooses not to
acknowledge such cases cases when they
happen
he chooses not to remember for example
the worst police shooting ever caught on
film the one where Daniel shaver an
unarmed white man is executed in the
middle of a hotel hallway while on his
knees begging for his life
shaver skin color makes a story
inconvenient and so it's simply ignored
like so many other stories just like it
Jones got to this narrative early and uh
many soon followed though over the past
few days Twitter has been full of tweets
like this one from anti-racism educator
quote unquote Tim Wise who says anyone
who says the killing of Tyree Nichols
can't be about racism because the cops
were also black really doesn't
understand how white supremacy or
anti-blackness work
and then Congressman Maxwell Alejandro
Frost says doesn't matter what color
those police officers are the murder of
Tyree Nichols is anti-black and the
result of a system built on white
supremacy
political commentator Monday or Jones
tweeted if you think the Memphis police
officers had to be white in order to
exhibit anti-blackness you need to take
that AP African-American studies course
Ron DeSantis just banned
it is of course more accurate to say
that if you think violence committed by
five black men is somehow there is the
fault of anti-black racism
then you've probably taken way too many
African-American studies courses
in fact that kind of insane paranoid
thinking exactly is exactly why those
sorts of courses shouldn't exist in
public school in the first place
and you could find this kind of
messaging of course Elsewhere on social
media like on Tick Tock where this white
woman explains why every white person is
directly guilty of carrying out this
beating you may think you have a good
alibi
maybe because you were in bed asleep in
your home 500 miles away while it was
happening but that doesn't mean you
aren't culpable she explains
I got a message today for some white
people if we have white people
listening paying attention I wouldn't
mind if you would do this with me we rub
our chests we find our heartbeat
and we say we did this
white supremacy did this
I'm talking about Tyree Nichols
police didn't do this
the Memphis Police Department didn't do
this
white supremacy did this
well I say we take her confession
seriously if she says she did this then
arrest and charge her sentence her to
life in a Maximum Security Prison
after all she says that she beat a black
man to death
worst she apparently did it through some
kind of mind control mechanism
you know the uh the black cops were the
ones doing the kicking and punching but
she says they didn't do this
she says it explicitly they did not do
this
this weird white woman with the GI Joe
buzz cut says that she was the one
really pulling the strings I mean she
says us we but uh I mean I I was I had
nothing to do with it but so if she sang
that she was arrest her interrogate her
find out who her accomplices were
if she doesn't give them up then throw
her in prison for the rest of her life
drop the charges on the cops and throw
her behind bars I would I would
unironically support that just she
confessed she said they didn't do it put
her in jail then
let's see how deep her white guilt
really runs
but it's not just idiots on Tick Tock
with this message the idiot running the
largest city in the United States was uh
singing the same tune here's mayor Eric
Adams
let me ask you the chief CJ day this one
in my interview with her she said that
all the officers being black it takes
race off the table do you agree with
that
uh no no I don't uh I think that I
understand what uh the chief was saying
and I think she uh really handled this
situation in a very professional Way She
Moves swiftly she's sure that those
officers were removed from the
Department she took all the necessary
steps uh but I think a race is still on
the table of when a culture of policing
historically has treated those from
different groups differently uh even
when the individuals are from that same
group that culture can still exist and
we have to zero in on it being honest
about it and making sure that we
properly train police for the realities
of the cities that they are policing in
right it's the system it's the culture
racism white supremacy
the left will blame everyone and
everything except the guys who actually
did it
and this is often the case you may
notice not just in this situation
whenever something bad happens they
point the figure finger in every
direction
other than the direction where the
culprit is actually standing
these people would be very bad at the
game of Clue I can't imagine I mean even
if all the evidence suggests that the
murder was carried out by you know
Colonel Mustard with a Candlestick in
the dining room they will still declare
that it was ultimately systemic racism
and economic inequality and a lack of
Common Sense Candlestick control that
really killed the victim
they view everything through this lens
partly because it's of course more
politically useful
um why is that well because there isn't
much political utility in actually
blaming an individual for his own
actions
because an individual is small and and
limited and finite
there's only so much you can do to
harvest an individual's actions for
political purposes now systems on the
other hand systems well those are
Bountiful Fields indeed politically
speaking
and then beyond the political the left
is also philosophically committed to a
view of life that denies the individual
Free Will and agency
they cannot accept that a person might
make his own choices and choose to do an
evil thing
and actually be culpable for that choice
because in the end he has power over
himself
if they accept such a proposition then
all kinds of scary Boogeyman like
personal responsibility and moral
standards and good versus evil come
rushing in and they can't have that
but the concern obviously that arches
over all of this is the racial narrative
and the narrative demands that every
evil that befalls a black person
must be explained in terms of white
racism
and they are committed to this idea too
and cannot abandon it either
because if they were to admit
if they were to admit I mean think about
if they were to admit that perhaps
Nichols was beaten to death by five cops
for some other reason
whatever the reason is because the cops
are poorly trained or they had a
personal Grudge or they just happen to
be bad and violent people
Etc
if they were to admit that
then they would be conceding that
incidents of police brutality or alleged
police brutality can be explained that
way which then raises the question about
whether such alleged incidents carried
out by white cops might also be
explained that way
it doesn't make sense to say that black
cops beat a black man because of racism
but it makes even less sense to say that
every black man beaten by a white cop is
the victim of racism while the black on
black incidents have a variety of other
non-racial explanations because if they
have non-racial explanations then again
why couldn't the white on black
incidents potentially have non-racial
explanations as well I mean you have you
have entered into consideration other
possibilities that would now have to be
thought about
even when it's a white on black
situation
their narrative puts them in a bind
and the only way out is through
either everything can be explained by
racism
or they must face the possibility
that lots of things are not explained by
racism
the latter is untenable
so the former it is
now let's get to our headlines
well you know it's tough to stick to
those New Year's resolutions but I'll
give you one that is easy to accomplish
even if you're a lazy SOB like me you
can complete your will with epic will
today that's an easy one to accomplish
for just 119 and as little as five
minutes epic will can help you create
your last will and testament living will
and even Healthcare power of attorney
their step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy to do all you need to do
is just fill in the blanks it's as
simple as that fifty percent of
Americans don't have a will will choose
today to be in that smarter half go to
epicwell.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Walsh
now of course the irony here is that if
you're looking for a systemic
explanation for The Tyree Nichols
situation there actually is a very
plausible one but it's just not one that
the left wants to pursue or talk about
um and even if you find a systemic even
if there are systemic elements to what
happened which I think there are we'll
talk about a second uh that still does
not this does not exonerate the
individual from being responsible for
their own actions
but as far as systems go
New York Post has this report at least
two out of the five Memphis police
officers charged with murder and the
Fatal Beatdown of Tyree Nichols joined
the force after the department relaxed
its hiring requirements to Darius bean
and Demetrius Haley
both joined the Memphis Police
Department in August 2020 more than two
years after the department dramatically
loosened the education qualifications to
become an officer recruits no longer
need an associate's degree or 54 college
credit hours to join the force and can
get by with five years of work
experience
loosening the required qualifications
however means that the department is
ultimately getting less desirable job
candidates Mike Alcazar and Adjunct
professor at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice and retired NYPD
detective told the post uh he said quote
they're desperate they want police
officers al-qarez said they're going
through it they check off some boxes
saying okay they're good enough get them
on
the department showed signs of struggle
with uh recruiting new officers offering
fifteen thousand dollar signing bonuses
2021 and 2022 according to Fox 13.
as of January 22nd MPD was down roughly
500 officers
um according to the news Outlet
last year the department lowered its
standards again for new recruits mixing
the time the timed physical ability test
and cutting college education
requirements from 54 credit hours to
just 24. the department also revealed
that um was even it was even offering
waivers for people who have been
convicted on felony charges
so bringing the standards down
and why this is happening in police
departments all across the country why
is it happening uh partly it's because
they want to diversify their ranks and
this is one of the solutions we were
told after um
George Floyd even though he died of a
fentanyl overdose and they all blame it
on the police officer but after that
happened they said well one of the
solutions here is we need to we need we
need the police departments to uh better
reflect and look like the communities
they're policing so they want to
diversify and that's part of the reason
they lower the standards the other
reason is that they're just finding it
difficult to find police officers
who
want to deal with any of this
as Society becomes more and more
anti-cop and as the media you know is
looking to pounce on any police officer
well not any
any police officer Who's involved in a
physical altercation with a black person
they're looking to pounce no matter the
the circumstances
and um if you also know if you're a comp
that you're going to be tried in the
court of public opinion you're going to
be tried in the media before you ever
get a fair trial and there's a good
possibility that you never will get a
fair trial Because by the time you get
to trial the jury pool is already
tainted by the fact that the media has
called you you know a racist killer and
and even your own department has has
labeled you that way like the president
United States is saying it so people are
looking at all this and of course saying
I I have no interest in this
why would I want to put myself in this
position
and so they're lowering the requirements
it could also be said that when you when
you uh cut off funding to police
departments
or you redirect because remember they
told us that when they said well we said
defund the police we didn't mean
literally defund them we just meant
redirect the funds somewhere else
well they've been doing that in many
cities as well you redirect the funds
somewhere else then you don't have the
funds to train to properly equip and
train police officers
you notice something that's um
when it comes to almost anything else
especially any other government
agency program government activity
the left will say that the solution is
always more funding
this is especially the case in the
education system so if there's a problem
with kids not getting a good education
if there's a problem with uh with a
teachers not being good at their jobs if
there's any kind of problem in the
education system whatsoever the solution
is always more funding for education
and the reason why this problem exists
is always that well they don't have
enough funding
so this is what they say in education
but with policing somehow the solution
is not to fund not to give more funding
but to take funds away
which is very interesting
you know there's good evidence that the
police chief herself has benefited
potentially from the same
um lowering of standards and you know
possibly for affirmative action type
reasons she's a black woman and this was
you know this is again this is this was
part of the solution we were told to the
alleged problems in police departments
is uh diversify them get women in there
get uh just just anything but white
males is what you want
well the post-millennial has this story
Chief Sarah and Davis of the men's
Memphis Police Department which is at
the center of attention as protests of
the Fatal police beating of Tyree
Nichols sweep the nation was previously
fired by the Atlanta Police Department
after being accused of attempting to
cover up the sex crimes of a co-worker's
husband
as the Hastings Tribune reports Davis
was terminated from a position as apd's
internal affairs Commander for her
alleged involvement in a botched sex
crimes investigation into the husband of
an Atlanta police sergeant according to
the report two detectives claimed Davis
instructed them to not investigate the
suspected Predator who was uh named
Terrell Marion crane after police
discovered sexually explicit images of
him with minor girls
crane was later indicted by Federal
grand jury on charges of producing child
pornography to which he pleaded guilty
to one count in January 2009.
the case required a Federal indictment
due to Atlanta police taking no action
according to the publication an
investigation conducted by the city
later found that Davis was at fault for
her inaction
then Chief Richard Pennington first
demoted the longtime law enforcement
official from major to Lieutenant before
deciding to fire her though she was
ultimately reinstated after challenging
the decision with Atlanta's Civil
Service Board
okay so she's implicated and uh in
covering up sex crimes
of a guy who ends up being convicted of
child pornography
and she's demoted and then fired
from her position in Atlanta
but then ends up getting hired to run a
police department
how exactly does that happen
I mean how do you go from you're fired
on suspicions of corruption
and then next thing you know you're
running the police department in Memphis
was there potentially some lowering of
standards that happened there as well
that seems pretty obvious but what we
know which is even more obvious
is that the left
they don't care at all about police
reform or corruption
this is one of the biggest
misconceptions in politics is that the
left is their their anti-cop they're
anti-police uh they are very deeply
concerned about police reform police you
know they they want to Tamp down on
corruption and policing and incompetence
in policing
they don't care about any of that
they do not care at all about any of
that
what they care about is the racial
narrative
the political narrative
and how these things can be exploited
that's all they care about
which is also by the way you know the
the other thing we didn't we didn't talk
about are the actual protests and
rioting that happened after this video
was released on Friday night
and remember they they built it up they
talked about how horrible it was they
got all the protesters
gathered in Downtown Memphis
and CNN was covering in they were saying
all the protesters gathered they're
waiting for the release of the it's like
like I talked about last week they're
treating like some sort of Hollywood
Premiere okay this was not a Friday news
dump this was a premiere date hey
everyone Gather in the city let's get
all fired up and angry and then we'll
drop this video right into the middle of
that
and it would seem like I mean if you
wanted to encourage writing there'd be
no better way to do it
and then they dropped the video
and it was a brutal and horrifying video
and
um yeah there were there were protests
across the country and there was some
rioting and there was some looting that
happened which is terrible
but it really has been
not anywhere close to George Floyd 2020
levels
even though everyone agrees like I I
haven't heard anyone say otherwise
everyone agrees that the Tyree Nichols
video is far worse than George Floyd
okay
um
now from my perspective it's not hard
for it to be worse than George Floyd
considering he was in the middle of
dying of a drug overdose but but all the
same
everyone agrees with that and I haven't
heard anyone even defend the police
officer the most anyone has said is like
they which I said they deserve their
time in court in essential proven guilty
of course but based on what we're seeing
it's um really a horrifying video
and yet it hasn't reached that level the
rioting has not reached anywhere close
to that level
and that's because they don't have the
racial angle there are some other
factors too it's a little bit cold
rioters they you know Riders and looters
um they're
they're sensitive to weather conditions
I think the history has proven that
but even more so it's just they don't
have the racial angle and it takes the
wind out of their cells it takes the
wind out of the cells of the media too
they're trying to they're trying to find
a racial angle in it but it's not going
to stick and they know it
which is why I just checked uh checked
CNN's website and The Tyree Nichols
story is already below the top headline
which has nothing to do with Tyree
Nichols and it's even Below on their uh
on the if you go on on mobile anyway
they've got their top story and then a
review of uh The Last of Us the last
episode of The Last of Us on HBO and
then there's another story and there's a
story about Ashley Judd and then below
that you have Tyree Nichols
compared to George Floyd where he was
like the top story for I don't know
three months
without the racial angle it just uh
quickly goes away
and
nowhere is that more evident than
you know in any case
where a white person
is killed by police
so we know if it's white officers
killing a black person we know what they
do with that if it's black officers
killing a a black person they're going
to try to find something in it that they
can talk about
but if it's a white person being killed
by cops that just never makes the
headlines ever
that is never a major headline story
ever there are there are never Mass
protests on that ever
because they don't care
all right just as the show ended on
Friday news broke that um would seem to
be the Epic conclusion of the bizarre
Paul Pelosi Saga uh finally we got the
body cam footage from the night when
Pelosi was bludgeoned by a hammer
wielding attacker
the footage that footage doesn't really
answer any questions in and of itself
actually it raises more questions than
it answers all we see is Pelosi answer
the door for the cops standing with uh
the guy David de Pap is his name I
believe and um
they but they both kind of have their
hands on uh on on the hammer that that
depay brought into the house and then
the Pape hits him over the head with it
and that's what we see in the video it's
a very strange clip also brutal
but shortly after that the 9-1-1 call
was released
and this I think sort of makes
everything pretty clear remember there
were many questions about how this guy
ended up in the house did Pelosi know
him was this as some speculated some
kind of like male escort hired to come
to the house and it was a lover's
quarrel that was the theory being
bandied about on Twitter quite a bit
um all of those speculations were
rampant on the internet rampant because
as always we weren't being given the
whole story they were being oddly
secretive about it so people speculate
when you're secretive you don't tell
people the story they speculate that's
what happens
now that we have this to go along with
um security camera footage which is the
third thing they released now all these
things they got body camera footage 911
call security camera footage
they kept all of this for months didn't
show anybody and then all at once they
released all of it and we also see
security camera footage of the Pape
actually breaking into the house
smashing the glass in the back coming
into the house and then there's the call
and let's listen to a little bit of the
call here it is
it's a San Francisco police do you need
help
oh what are the Hillman uh here just
waiting for my wife to come back
uh he's just uh waiting for her to come
back because she's not going to be here
for a day so I just left away
zero okay do you need to please fire a
medical for anything eight seconds uh I
I don't think so I don't think so
zero two twenty three and probably eight
seconds yeah there's the uh
um
is the Capitol Police around 220.
they usually here they're usually here
at the house protecting my wife uh no
this is San Francisco police Friday
October I I no I understand
um
2022. okay well zero um
[Music]
uh
he thinks everything's good I I've got a
problem but he thinks everything's good
this element just uh came out of the
house uh and he wants to wait here for
my wife to come home zero and so uh four
and forty eight anyways do you know who
the person is
no I don't know who he is he he is okay
so uh he has now we started to see why I
think they didn't want to release the
call uh is it's because it it makes the
911 operator look terrible I mean it
look it makes the police response the
emergency response look absolutely awful
and I understand that we have the
benefit of hindsight and we have more of
the context than she had on the call but
this is also what you do for a living
and um
she just would not pick up the hint like
it could not have been more clear first
of all he says when they're getting my
wife is Nancy Pelosi so you know my
wife's Nancy Pelosi someone is here
waiting for her
I'm calling 9-1-1 because someone is
waiting for my wife named Nancy Pelosi
wink wink
she wouldn't pick up on the end like
clearly uh Paul Pelosi is trying to ask
for help without actually saying it
because the crazy guy the meth head who
broke into the house is standing there
with a hammer and so he probably gave uh
to Pape some excuse and said oh you want
my wife well sure I'll call the police
and they'll bring it right over and um
and then he's he's standing there and
and Paul Pelosi is trying to convey this
to the 91 operator without saying it out
loud
I can't get over the part where she
where she actually says
he says oh yeah well uh the guy who came
into my house says there's not a problem
I think there is a problem but he says
they're not then I went out 9-1-1
operator says okay well give us a ring
back uh if you need anything
okay well sounds like everything's
totally fine on your end
talk to you later
could not possibly be more oblivious
so this
to me is pretty clear what happened this
is a crazy
homeless drug adult
free Coop came into the house and is uh
and Bob Pelosi probably woke up he was a
little bit flustered into what's going
on he called police tried to get them to
come over he was trying to keep the guy
calm and then everything proceeded from
there so pretty clear now
so what's the real story here
well the real story as I said from the
beginning
is that and this is not me moving the
goal posts now there were some people on
the right who really fully bought into
the theory that this was like a Lover's
spat between Paul Pelosi and a gay male
escort this was this was some people on
the right
they assume that and fully bought into
it and that's what they believed
now from my perspective from the
beginning I said well that's that's one
Theory that's that
that's that's a potentially plausible
Theory only because and the fact that
they're being secretive and not giving
us more information like why couldn't
you release the 91 call the next day
there's no reason why you couldn't have
in many other cases they do
so when they're secretive about
something you start to suspect well
maybe there's a reason why they're being
secretive what could those reasons be
that was only one Theory what I said
from the beginning is that
the the other potential explanation
which is that this is San Francisco
and a violent homeless drug addict broke
into the house and was acting crazy that
is also perfectly plausible
given that it's San Francisco I would
assume that kind of thing happens in San
Francisco all the time
maybe not breaking the house the middle
of night but encounters with violent
crazy drug addicts in San Francisco are
very common
and so there's nothing implausible about
it
the real story then is that they tried
to make this local crime story
in San Francisco into an indictment on
Republicans
they tried to make this David the Pape
guy who was hopped up on drugs and a
lunatic they tried to make him into a
some sort of conservative right-wing
militant
like he lived outside he lived in a bus
outside of a hippie commune with a BLM
flags and all that all the rest of it
and they try to make him to a right-wing
militant which he never was
is he a left-wing militant no he's just
he's a crazy guy is what he is
that was very clear from the very
beginning
but they try to take up what is what
always seemed to me to be and clearly
now is a local crime story in San
Francisco and making an indictment on
Republicans which is just as absurd as
taking Tyree Nichols and making it an
indictment of so-called white supremacy
just as absurd
really what the lesson that we should
take from this is that the crime
in San Francisco
where Nancy Pelosi lives and the area
she represents the crime is so bad there
that it's now spilling out into her own
neighborhood
and she doesn't live in the Inner City
which I'm sure is shocking to learn
so it's now spilling out into the nice
parts of San Francisco
and the Democrat officials who have um
been in control who've been in power
have overseen San Francisco's slide into
this crime-ridden post-apocalyptic
hellscape they are now
having to
you know face the the Frankenstein
monster that they created
that to me is the story
all right
I gotta I gotta leave some time for this
because this is my favorite story
of the year so far uh easily and
potentially of the century I don't know
but it's a good one so the ISU European
figure skating championships at espoo
Metro Arena
took place last week whereas espoo Metro
Arena I have no idea
somewhere in Europe we can assume and it
began with what was billed as a
spectacular opening ceremony meant to
celebrate equality and diversity that's
what it was about and for a little more
on this ceremony here's the write-up on
the espoo 2023 website it says this
the ISU European figure skating
championship at espu Metro Arena will
begin on Wednesday 25th 25th of January
with a spectacular opening ceremony
drawing its inspiration from the event's
theme which is just Bu The Finnish
figure skating Association promotes the
importance of equality and diversity and
develops skating according to its values
the theme just just bu will be visible
part of the opening ceremony with
performers from various backgrounds the
half hour opening ceremony was designed
by synchronized skating coach Helena
tynhara together with choreographer and
Coach uh with a name that I'm not going
to pronounce
quote with the diverse group of
performers we want to show that the ice
has space for everyone the opening
ceremony will present skaters at various
levels from non-professionals to top
athletes on the ice we will see single
skater synchronized skaters and pairs
including included among the performers
are figure skater Nina Maria
anti-kinen who defines herself as a
gender-neutral woman and then other
performers as well okay so
Mina Maria auntie kainen
about this fellow and it is a fellow
first of all this is a man he is a
Finnish dude in his 60s and is
apparently always dreamed of being an
ice princess is what he has said and he
now identifies as a woman and as an ice
princess and so they put him out on the
ice for the opening ceremony of this
what I what I think is like a major
figure skating event
and um
we'll show you what that looks like and
and uh
well first of all before we show you the
video I think we have a just a
photograph of the guy himself could we
put that up on the screen
do we have the photo of the actual ice
skater okay there he is
so looks a bit like maybe a uh
a cross-dressing Tommy Lee Jones perhaps
you know he actually looks like Stephen
King a little bit he looks like like a
creepy somehow a creepier Stephen King
if Stephen King was a character in a
Stephen King novel then that's what that
guy is
um in other words a truly beautiful
woman and if you don't think I mean look
at this
lovely lady lady right here if you don't
think that this is the most beautiful
and gorgeous and graceful
female athlete you have ever laid your
eyes on then you are literally Hitler
that's the truth
if you do not applaud his sorry her ice
skating performance as the most
impressive athletic display of all time
you are also Hitler
which means that they're going to be a
lot of Hitlers out there after we all
watch this performance together so let's
put this up this this was Maria
Nina Maria's performance on the ice no
not this one that's that's next
yeah here it is go ahead
let's watch this again
yeah and this is actually impressive
because this is the first time
apparently he's been ice skating in his
life
I don't know what's more absurd that he
identifies as a woman or identifies as
an ice skater Falls
oh my God
what a performance remarkable you know
and the audience is just watching like
are we allowed to laugh at this are we
supposed to laugh at this the audience
has no idea and this is in Europe
especially they're they're very afraid
uh they don't know what they're supposed
to do
but they're really looking at each other
like is this supposed to be good what
are we supposed to do here
well you laugh at it that's what you're
supposed to do
um that's what you're meant to do
honestly I took my kids I think I
mentioned this I took my kids ice
skating a couple of weeks ago and um it
was my
maybe third time ever putting on ice
skates and the other two times were I
don't know 20 years ago on like a date
or something and I was more graceful
than that and I'm I'm not even
exaggerating I was significantly better
than that
compared to that guy I'm practically
I can't name any famous figure skaters
so I can't really finish the analogy but
whatever's the most famous one I'm
practically that person compared to that
guy but it gets better uh because this
guy also this actually is not his first
time strap it on the skates he also
competed at an event in 2020 where he
gave a performance that was uh inspired
by Japanese culture
let's watch this one
[Music]
I mean this
this in every sense looks like a scene
from a Will Ferrell movie in 2003
but it's not this is real
[Music]
you know what's strange he's actually
gotten worse in the last two years
because this is a little bit better than
what we just saw
he's regressing
[Music]
look at that okay he's on one leg
I don't know I don't know if I could do
that I didn't try
all right
not a joke
oh it does a little uh twirly thing
well
that's how is it how is that better that
was it was three years ago how has it
gotten worse since then
I don't know if it's the the hormones
they have them on or what
so this one is good because this is like
an appropriation hat trick he's
appropriating Womanhood appropriating
Japanese culture and appropriating
figure skating all at the same time
but this is how the appropriation math
works it actually cancels so you would
think well that's three times more
offensive than than other forms of
appropriation
um no because it actually it cancels it
all cancels each other out and um
because he's appropriating Womanhood at
the same time as appropriating Japanese
culture it cancels out and then it
actually becomes uh not only something
that's okay and appropriate but
something that we should celebrate
and I do celebrate it and so I I'd like
to see more I want this guy in the
Olympics okay I want him winning gold as
a female figure skater in the Olympics
let's just go all the way and make
everything into a total mockery
because that's all it is
all right let's get to the comment
section
it's all alone
[Music]
Captain Morgan Kayla says Matt nothing
would give me Greater Joy than to hear
you comment on Dylan Mulvaney's new face
reveal on Monday's show every time I
hear you mention his name I cackle
because I know what's about to follow
his pure gold well I'm going to
disappoint you Captain Morgan because I
have nothing funny to say about Buffalo
Bill Mulvaney who did reveal his
his new face after having Face
feminization surgery where they shaved
down the face like they cut into it to
make it more quote unquote feminine
which is which is
kind of funny to me to begin with
because this guy apparently thought
that his face was too masculine before
this
like that was his problem
that would be like if if I went and got
hair transplants for my beard to make my
beard thicker is if that of all my
physical problems if as if that's the
one that I need to focus on
and of all of Mulvaney's problems a
masculine face and physique has never
been one of them though he is still a
man okay even if a non-masculine one he
can carve his face into whatever shape
he wants to carve it into he could
become like uh he could become like
Leatherface and start stitching other
people's faces onto his own not to give
him any ideas here but uh even then he
would still be himself
anyway like I said I have nothing to say
about Dylan Mulvaney no matter what he
does he still looks like a Crispin
Glover and Back to the Future anyway so
it doesn't matter
diabolic Doug says I love the pickle the
ADL splc
Etc are in by having to choose between
allowing Matt to go about life
uninterrupted and unimpeded or choosing
to focus their attention write a unique
report on all the ways Matt's beliefs
make Steam come out of their ears and
present him with the honor of most
dangerous to their grip on power
congratulations well that's that's
any any of us who speak up against the
left this is the bind that we put them
in is that uh is that
if they complain about us and call us
names we just laugh about it
and they the more dangerous they make us
seem the the more flattering it is
but then at the same time if they ignore
us then we just that's fine too because
then I can without being annoyed by all
the yapping in my ears then I could just
go ahead and do what I'm gonna do
um so no matter what they kind of lose
and that's the great thing
Daniel Lisa says I wish Matt would
address the issue of false
incriminations whether it happened
intentionally or by mistake when
discussing capital punishment well yeah
this is uh maybe the most common
argument against capital punishment is
that what do you do if uh if someone is
falsely convicted and they end up being
executed and then obviously it's that's
an irreversible
procedure let's say and then if it turns
out that they were innocent then you've
killed innocent man the common refrain
that we hear is that well it's better to
let uh 100 guilty men go free than to
execute one innocent man
and on that that latter point
I'm not actually sure that's
the case like I don't know that that's
the ethically correct way of looking at
it that it's better for a hundred guilty
people to go free than to execute an
innocent man
um
I mean maybe I could be persuaded of
that but I think it's the kind of thing
you have to argue for you can't just
state it as if it's
self-evidently correct I don't think it
is self-evident and it's an interesting
question but
because when you when you
yes if you uh if you are accidentally
you know executing an instant man it's
almost falsely convicted it's not known
by the justice system that he was
falsely convicted he ends up being
executed
that's a horrific tragedy there's no
question about it
and then you have lost and innocent life
however if you let a hundred guilty men
go free especially guilty men who
otherwise would have been executed then
now how many innocent lives will be
killed because of that
more than one we can assume
so how do you how do you weigh those
things it becomes an interesting ethical
question but just it's it's a question
that I think has to be fleshed out I I
don't think we can simply assume again
that uh well it's better but let a
million guilty men go free into society
if it means we could save one innocent
person again not so sure about that
but
um to your actual question
I think that it is possible these days
to be nearly 100 certain that someone is
guilty
uh now you could argue that you could
never be certain but then in a sense you
can never be certain of anything like I
I'm
as certain as can be
that I'm not going to see an elephant
flying through that you know I'm not
gonna look at my window here and see an
elephant flying across over the trees
especially because
you know the trees are fake but even if
they weren't
allegedly fake
like I'm pretty sure I'll never see a
flying elephant okay I'm nearly certain
but it is like technically a philosopher
would say well it's it's logically
possible it could you can't say that
it's totally impossible that it would
happen well sure
I'm as certain as can be and I think we
could be just about that certain when it
comes to convicting uh people of of
capital crimes these days because of DNA
evidence because of uh you know every
all the security footage evidence and
phones and the way things are tracked
and credit card and like all these
things together
can lead you to near 100 certainty and
also a lot of times you have confessions
in many cases you have people admitting
that they did it
so I had all that together I think you
could be nearly 100 certain
um enough more than enough to morally
justify uh the death penalty
now what about in societies where they
don't necessarily have the technology to
be that certain of somebody's guilt
uh well then you could justify a death
penalty on different grounds because if
they don't have that kind of Technology
if this is like a third world country or
something not as developed country then
then there's a whole other reason for
the death penalty which is that you're
not gonna you probably don't have the
infrastructure and the ability to keep
dangerous people in prison indefinitely
you know for life you don't you don't
have that ability to do it and then and
then the death penalty becomes even more
necessary arguably for that reason alone
so uh one way or another I think it
leads to the death penalty being
Justified
Templar turd
all right says
um before watching Matt I would get very
defensive when I would be called a
homophobe and transphobe but now
whenever I'm called these things I tell
them that I'm very flattered and I'm
thankful that they recognize me for who
I am thank you Matt Walsh that's and
that's a fine way of responding just
being totally dismissive and in a you
know in a snide and sarcastic way
embracing the label that they put on you
it's fine it's fine to respond that way
it as long as really any response to the
labels is fine as long as you are not
responding by trying to desperately
defend yourself against the label the
moment you do that you lose
and anything else whether you're
dismissing whether you're joking about
it whatever else you do is fine as long
as it is in the end basically a
dismissive response that that is the
only there are many forms of a
dismissive response to that but that is
the only way to respond when someone
thinks that they can defeat your
argument simply by labeling you oh
you're well you're a homophobe and
that's it
um an example of this I was uh talking
last week about bad art you know we
talked about that on uh whenever it was
Wednesday or something
and the proliferation of bad art and I
mentioned this on Twitter and I was
accused of racism I was accused of
racism
for criticizing bad art and the reason I
was racist is that it was just one
person accuse me hundreds of people
saying I was racist because
some of the bad art that I cited was
made by black artists and so this became
a racist dog whistle where really I was
saying that I don't want black people
making art is what they claimed and
there was one guy in particular who
responded to me and this is a guy's name
is Ahmed Baba says care to elaborate on
what you mean by they because I wrote in
the Tweet uh they make bad art or
whatever and yeah care to elaborate on
what you mean by they let's see how deep
you can dig this hole you're in
and that that really rubbed me the wrong
way uh not only because you have the
totally baseless racism claim but also
you're in a hole now let's see you dig
your way out of this hole
who says I'm in a hole I don't care if
you think I'm not I'm I'm standing up
here on level ground I know what hole
you think I'm in that I have to dig out
of
So I responded to him that it said hi
I'm Ed you can interpret my statements
however you want in your own fevered
imagination I truly don't care and I
don't feel the need to justify myself to
you please take your tiresome race
banding routine to someone who gives a
thanks and have a great evening I
think that's a fine way of responding as
well but no matter what
the point is I'm not here to justify
myself I don't well I interpret what you
said as racist okay then you do I don't
that's how you that's how you have
chosen to see it that's in your own mind
you have invented this is that my it's
not my job to talk you down from that
so go ahead and go off you you can go
live the rest of your life thinking that
I'm a racist because I don't like
bad sculptures you can live the rest of
your life thinking that doesn't mean
anything to me I don't care
well if you're a parent then you know
that the radical left has infiltrated
every aspect of your kids lives from
Academia to medicine to Children's
programming they are pushing a woke
agenda at every turn and doing
everything they can to capture their
hearts and Minds if you're a parent then
this is deeply concerning and you may
feel powerless to stop the onslaught but
the good news is that many are finding a
way to fight back that's why I'm excited
to tell you about a brand new book
published by DW books written by Bethany
Mandel and Carol Markowitz it's um it's
called stolen youth how radicals are
erasing innocence an indoctrinating a
generation and in stolen youth an
excellent book they share testimonials
from parents who are witnessing just how
far and out of control the agenda has
become in corrupting our morals and um
and it's also one that was exacerbated
during the pandemic this is an absolute
must read for parents who want to
understand how we got here what we're up
against and also most importantly how to
go on the offensive how to fight back
how to save our kids stolen youth how
radicals are erasing innocence and
indoctrinated generation comes out on
March 7th but if you click on the Amazon
Link in the description you can
pre-order your copy today you don't want
to miss it make sure you do that now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
growing up in the 90s we saw many
one-hit wonders come and go they'd pop
onto the music scene with a piece of
melodic and lyrical Brilliance like
Macarena or tub thumping or Mambo Number
Five and their songs would be
inescapable for five and a half months
piping through every speaker ubiquitous
floating on the breeze almost uh almost
becoming a part of the atmosphere and
then just as suddenly both the song and
the musical act that produced it would
disappear and we would never hear from
Lou Bega or Chumbawamba or whoever made
the Macarena ever again maybe they turn
up again briefly years later in a VH1
where are they now segment but usually
they simply faded from view entirely
leaving us to wonder whether they ever
actually existed
that's not how things work anymore these
days nobody ever goes away nobody ever
Fades from view we are not permitted to
forget about anyone no matter how much
we may want to because we're all
connected we're caught on the same web
and so everyone has their 15 minutes of
fame but the 15 minutes never ends
and this is true on a personal level and
it's also true in pop culture where most
pop artists are at most capable of
producing one moderately listenable song
they're one real hit but then they
Linger on indefinitely clamoring for
attention usually in ways that have
nothing to do with the music
and in recent years especially a
marginal pop star who already released
their one arguably decent or at least
maybe not completely terrible song while
cling desperately to relevance by doing
two things one becoming increasingly
vulgar and explicitly sexual and two
coming out of the closet and often
they'll come out of multiple closets
they'll come out of the closet multiple
times finding one closet after another
to emerge from we may call this the Demi
Lovato strategy though she neither
invented it nor is she the only pop star
to utilize it some came before her and
many have came after her and this is the
case certainly for uh the singer named
Sam Smith you may remember Sam Smith as
the guy who made that one song 10 years
ago stay with me is what it was called
and it enjoyed its five and a half
months of cultural ubiquity and it was
around the same time that Smith came out
of his first closet announcing to the
world that he was gay
and that Revelation didn't do much to
generate any extra interest or fame for
Sam Smith as we all kind of assume at
this point that every pop star is gay so
he said hey I'm gay and we all said uh
yeah okay
we figured perhaps disappointed that he
didn't get more publicity mileage out of
his sexual preferences Smith began re
revealing deeper and deeper levels to
his gayness like the gay equivalent of a
Russian doll and just like an actual
Russian doll the smaller thing disguised
inside the larger thing is just a
smaller version of the larger thing so
it just kind of repeats itself in this
infinite regress a few years later Smith
came out as gender queer explaining that
he quote feels as much like a woman as a
man
he was of course never asked to explain
what the hell that's supposed to mean or
how he knows what a woman feels like or
how he delineates between man feelings
and woman feelings
it's good for his sake that he wasn't
asked these questions because he
wouldn't have been able to answer them
because the term genderqueer is
completely meaningless
but genderqueer Sam Smith was about as
interesting to the public as gay Sam
Smith so he went back to the drawing
board and two years after that he came
out of his third closet he announced
that he's actually not just gay not just
genderqueer but in fact non-binary and
will now use they them pronouns
how does being non-binary differ in any
meaningful sense from being genderqueer
and what does any what do any of these
terms mean and in what way is he not
simply just a gay guy with feminine
mannerisms like a million other gay guys
well again
he was never asked those questions and
couldn't have answered them if he had
been
another several years passed and Sam
Smith put out more music than nobody
cared about and he realized that simply
being a gay genderqueer non-binary they
them wasn't going to cut it
and that's when he decided that his only
path back to something approaching
cultural relevance was to become
basically the white male lizzo so Smith
packed on 150 pounds dressed up in an
outfit that reveals far more of his body
than any human on earth ever wanted to
see and he put out a new x-rated album
and music video
and he explained this this uh this new
artistic Direction in a recent interview
that um that where he explains that that
he knows that it's it's a risky move to
do this but he's bold enough to try it
listen
the music industry is just not used to
queer artists if there was a big risk
you took with this album what would you
say it was for yourself
I'd say the biggest risk on this album
was the element of sex
wow
the music industry isn't ready for queer
artists he says
which is a bit like claiming that zumba
isn't ready for middle-aged white women
he also says that the biggest risk he's
taking is being sexual
I mean that's a pretty big risk we have
to admit I mean it takes a lot of guts
to do the same thing that literally
every other person in your profession is
doing and has already done and has been
doing for decades
following the easiest and safest Trend
now there's a risk I mean that's
boldness if I ever saw it
next is going to tell me that he that he
went out on a limb and picked the Chiefs
to go to the Super Bowl this year
I mean this guy I mean sorry this them
he knows how to take risks big risks
granted he might be the first pop star
star to go this direction while looking
like he plays right tackle on the
Detroit Lions practice squad
though on second thought I guess uh
lizzo has him beat there as well so even
on that point he's he's not the first
so Smith's latest musical effort may not
be risky may not be bold may not be
revolutionary
but it is at least we will admit totally
repulsive and grotesque
and this is normally the part where I
would Play a clip of his disgusting
music video that has gone viral entirely
for being disgusting but I'm actually
not going to do that in this case so I'm
not going to force you to start your
Monday that way
um suffice it to say that Smith's new
music video for his song which is called
I'm not here to make friends shows the
morbidly obese singer and women's
underwear dancing awkwardly with both
men and women wearing something similar
to assless chaps who then start humping
the floor with their bare butts sticking
up at which point streams of P start
spraying all over them and it gets worse
from there but I'm realizing that
describing it may even be more
objectionable than just watching it so
you get the gist anyway
now
pointing out how morally debased all of
this is
just as it's no use observing how our
society day by day comes to not only
resemble but in every sense rival Sodom
and Gomorrah and that call that all goes
without saying at this point and it's
also exactly what these
attention-starved ugly degenerate morons
want us to say
it is true that Sam Smith is a filthy
hideous pervert it's also true that he
wants us to say that about him after all
as we've learned from all of the Sam
Smith that came before this Sam Smith
part of being a pervert is getting off
on other people noticing that you're a
pervert like the thrill he gets from
hearing people describing that way is
part of
why he's a pervert and what makes him a
pervert to begin with
which isn't to say that we shouldn't
point it out but rather that after we've
delivered the moral condemnation this
kind of garbage calls for and deserves
we should also say the thing that is
just as true
and also the one thing that Sam Smith
does not want us to say
the thing that those of his ilk fear the
most because they know it is true
is that this routine along with being
debased and disgusting and morally
prayed is also boring it is dirty and
stupid and gross and Evil
and totally utterly tiresome boring
played out we've seen it a million times
already
they cannot shock us anymore as a
culture we are sadly far too jaded to be
scandalized by anything you cannot
scandalize us you can't do it
our eyes and Minds have have grown
essentially calloused
we've been swimming in this muck and
filth for so long that another bucket
may be demoralizing and sad but it can
never shock us it can never surprise us
to be intentionally ugly in a world of
ugliness only means that you blend in
you become part of the background
now you may be noticed for a brief
moment but then you Fade Into the
surroundings and you become merely part
of the fecal flecked landscape
a decadent Society is very generous to
perverts in many ways but the one thing
that the perverts are forced to give up
the one price that they must pay is the
element of surprise
you can't surprise us anymore
and most of all they lose their status
as revolutionaries
they're not challenging the system but
rather acting as Guardians and
reinforcers of it
now if Sam Smith really wanted to shock
us
therefore he would have created
something good
something meaningful
something beautiful and and true
now that would be something we're not
used to okay you want to give the music
industry something it's not used to
how about beauty and Truth
but that requires Talent
and moral Clarity and an IQ somewhere
above the freezing point
which puts it out of Sam Smith's reach
and that is why Sam Smith is today
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion so let's
move over to the members block if you're
not a member yet you can become a member
and use code wall to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]